[Music]
okay thank you it's a pleasure to speak
here so I will talk about deep algebra
this is the my one of my research
programs in understanding text and in
understanding especially mathematical
texts so I should explain that my
background is pure mathematics I did my
PhD in mathematics in Paris then I was a
research fellow at Oxford for two years
and basically right now I'm working at
the Polish Academy of Sciences where I'm
a assistant professor and apart from
that I have my own company Alam AI where
we do this kind of research on the verge
of mathematics and computer science so
what I would be talking about is kind of
a program and I would try to promote
that program for you to join me in
helping me out because I need developers
and there's like low-hanging fruits in
terms of like what you can do and get
really nice publishable results and
papers so let me start with I will
assume that you know less about
mathematics and computer science so I'll
explain you how it's going with
mathematical research nowadays and what
are the problems within mathematics so
there's a growing number of mathematical
research published on archive so this is
the repository which probably know
because computer science papers also
appear on archive and the program of
mathematics is that it becomes more
complicated and interdependent and it's
impossible to verify the correctness for
the outsiders so you really have to have
the knowledge related to the particular
domain in order to be able to say that a
given proof is correct or not and even
though there's filler problems even for
a group of experts and one of the
problem the recent problem is that the
sapru feof one of the world well-known
conjecture ABC conjecture which was done
last year by Mochizuki which has like
1500 pages just white 1500 pages long
and actually there's no one who can
verify its correctness so you would like
to somehow be able to say that
the given proof is correct or not and
this is the starting point this is the
official stats on archive or of how many
papers there are and if you look at pure
mathematics around twenty thousand
submissions per year of mathematical
papers and each mathematical papers
contains at least one main theorem so
there are at least twenty thousand
theorems with proofs on archive every
year and it's growing so that's
problematic because you have to verify
all that and mostly the research is that
the research is done but then you have
to send it to a journal to have peer
review process and then that takes also
a lot of time so the potential solution
to that is automation or semi automation
of producing mathematics and verifying
already existing mathematics so that
it's it's all consistent and and then
you can in in the end that would serve
also a community of mathematicians to
produce better results to to produce
knowledge faster so what's being done
currently and there's some some kind of
research going on already for I guess at
least 20 years prior to any machine
learning so what people used to do is
that they take a mathematical work so
for example does this fight Thomason
theorem which is you might be aware of
like the classification of simple groups
and then they rewrite it in a in another
language Koch misery which is especially
custom to process mathematics and it's
somehow in between natural language that
the language in which mathematicians
write the papers and something which a
machine can understand
and once they rewrite and try to verify
it by using in inner logic of Koch
measure or other interactive your
improver so if you if you're interested
in that you can go for this reference
the developments in formal proofs and
and read more the only problem with that
approach that mathematical work is based
on the previous works so you have to
like foundations basically each time you
start something doing something so so
it's similar to like them understanding
the usual text even though the sentence
can be very simple you have the
background knowledge that you have to
understand in order to understand the
text with mathematics is easier become
because you can mostly choice all the
references to previous works but still
if you are trying to translate that into
one of those languages you have to get
all the references right and you have to
build a foundation so there were some
solutions like this misery math library
where they try to set like a standard
for like the common knowledge that
that's working to some extent but the
problem is that there's a tedious work
of flowing in gaps because human way of
writing mathematics is often much
different from what Cockrum user accepts
because there are gaps there like
simplifications there are things which
are obvious to the experts but not to
the machine and it's purely manual work
so okay yes so so for example it took
basically six years for fifteen
mathematicians to translate 100 pages
long paper and that's unsustainable in
the intel on go run because the
mathematic as I said they're like twenty
thousand submissions each year of
mathematical papers so you won't be able
to go together with them and then us
developments in order to analyze
everything and you have to do some kind
of ultimate a Shinto to follow but once
you're in cocaine easier there are a
growing number of methods to actually
verify correctness
so hommerson tactics I won't talk about
those this is very related to the
research done in those fields of formal
verification and there's some some
trials with mash and deep learning but
basically there's only one paper so far
on this topic this is the paper you see
at the bottom by those five people deep
mouth these deep and most of those
people are from Google and they tried
with something
very simple and they got they go to
dreading drastic results so I'm taking
this last perspective and trying to
think what you can do with machine
learning and deep learning here to apply
two mathematical texts and try to really
understand the text so my whole idea is
that mathematical texts are much simpler
than general text because you can you
don't have this grammar issues you just
have a pure text of logical sentences
and you basically want to conclude
whether from a and B you could whether a
and B implies C so so that's very simple
in terms of grammar issues but you only
have a lot of pure logic that you have
to understand okay but first of all if
you are going towards automation then of
course you need data for any kind of
mashing deploring so and and you need to
have a lot of data to do anything
meaningful so in particular you you
don't you can't do experiments on this
translated mathematics into Cockrum
easier because that takes too much of
the time so you have to invent something
else and try to automate translation so
my way of thinking somehow to omit
Otto's done before and just view
mathematics as any kind of natural
language and just try to so that was my
previous way of thinking about it that I
take a mathematical paper in lattic and
then I try to translate it into Kocher
Mesa where I can verify actually proof
but you can think maybe you know like
other proof assistants like something
where you can check logic the whole idea
is that you actually treat mathematics
another language where you can and
you're trying to build a dictionary
between the two languages so what I mean
but by building a dictionary is if you
know semantic parsers and how an LP is
done the new trying to enhance that with
something which appears only in
mathematics namely you would like to
have you'd like to be able to
distinguish between different level
level of abstraction so I
those kinds of types and variables which
are semantic types for those who know
type fury so the example is this so a
typical sentence you may find the
mathematical paper is let G be a group
those dollar signs are for lot egg and
in this in this example G is a variable
of type group so types are abstractions
and variables are like particular
realization of a given abstraction and
the whole idea is that you would like to
build a graph of knowledge of your
mathematical text first by tagging your
text in a very in like on a higher level
so apart from tagging it like in a
normal way by you know like tokenizing
you somehow would like to add also
different levels of abstraction and
create this graph of knowledge on a side
and then only translate it to cook and
measure and sentence by sentence and and
get additional structure where you can
which you can verify so there's a
reference of this a PhD thesis of gansta
lingam the language of mathematics where
he looks at the mathematics from the
standpoint of like oh not of natural
language so before that ok so anyway
even though so this is the architecture
or approach that I'm taking but you
still need a good source of data to
actually try it on and in particular you
would like to have data which is known
to be correct in the sense that already
verified by mathematicians so
peer-reviewed and big enough to do
something meaningful with it so so
that's where algebraic geometric comes
in so that's my speciality in
mathematics that's why it's close to my
heart but also apart from that it's like
it's very pure domain of mathematics and
its value are researched in particular
so it's abstracting the sense that it's
mostly by some concepts and not on like
different
kind of approximations and it's easier
for computer to process because it's
processing at the level of words rather
than numbers so you have very little
numbers numbers mostly symbols which you
have to process which is which is easier
to to deal with and also it has a very
good foundation especially this Stax
project that I mentioned so this is my
basically main source of our data from
mathematics which we use so let me
explain that
so the Stax project is a open
collaboration of multiple mathematicians
starting from scratch meaning from from
simple algebra from simple category
theorem and going to the modern research
and it's very well organized easy to
manage you have all this dependency
graphs of which theorem follows from
which which we can experiment with and
it's verified you know it's verified for
correctness so you can use it freely and
this is not even accurate so the stacks
project I write that it has five
thousand seven hundred pages but it has
over 6,000 pages right now you have a
API to query everything is intact you
can access all of the tag files it's
available free on the internet and
that's the fantastic source of free good
mathematics to use an experiment on and
this is what we're experimenting with so
how does it look like it's basically
like you have a lemma each lemma has a
lemma proposition if you're and whatever
has a tag which is immutable and then
you have a proof and you can also access
dependency graphs which are on the right
which shows basically so your lemma is
in the in the middle of the circle and
then all the lines are showing which
other limits are you using and that goes
basically back to that the axioms that
you have so the fantastic thing about
this tax product is that it's all the
references are inner and are within this
text project so you don't have to go and
treat like another three papers
outside of the Stax project everything
is in there so that's a great source for
like if you're trying to rezone upon
text because everything is going down to
the single six thousand pages document
yeah this is another view on that also
because you can like have these clusters
so basically yeah so the goal this is on
the on the next slide the goal is that
we want to enhance the semantic parses
with types and variables and build some
kind of structure like that from scratch
and then be able to use that also on
other mathematical papers but not only
mathematics so you somehow the way I
think about understanding text somehow
that you would like to create this graph
of knowledge and see different kind of
types variables and how different
concepts interact with each other and
how one concept is implied by the other
concept so you would like to create this
kind of dependency graphs also for other
scientific papers and not only
scientific papers bar but any paper
actually so this is somehow the basic
plan of the whole program and then you
know like the Stax project and then you
test and verify it on the archive so let
me go to national learning part and then
say something about like probably what
you want to hear so I'll STM's and stuff
like that so so there this is from
another side so one of the parts of what
I was talking about is this logical part
but machine learning is mostly started
well it is statistics so you're not
getting anything on the nose you're
getting something statistically true so
you have this amazing character level as
the ends which you can use to actually
learn the style of the text and it was
tested on the Stax project by karpati so
so you have this great references if you
posted an article on a blog two years
ago on
effectiveness of recurrent neural
networks and that was one of the
examples there are plenty others but
actually what he did was he trained this
character level and STM's from the Stax
project and then he tried to see what it
gets generated and actually generated
attack document which almost compiled in
Natick and it looked like algebraic
geometry so this is the result so it
looks basically exactly like in like
like a random page from the Stax project
meaning you have some kind of a few Ram
then you have some kind of a prove you
have as you see you have like lemma you
assume something but when you try to
read it it actually doesn't make sense
it's it looks nice it looks like
mathematics but it's not mathematics in
the sense that it's it's only
mathematics on the level of how it looks
but there's no logic in between it so
there's no logic in it so for example
like you see proof see discussion of
sheets of seeds that's so so that
doesn't make sense but they're like if
you just start to reading it it doesn't
make sense even though so the problem is
how to actually do something with it
because whether you can somehow enhance
it with inner logic to actually be able
to really make sense out of it and start
producing career in mathematics and
actually at least try verifying
mathematics to some level and this is
the idea behind meta tag so the whole
idea is that you would like to have
language on top of a standard tag which
has inherent logic to it and is able to
say that a given sentence is correct to
some extent so this is basically what
we're trying to do so on one hand ok
this is the idea build a logical
structure on top of tag and we want to
somehow attach a probability to a given
sentence which shows how true it is and
then be able to learn upon examples
language between fake and true sentence
sentences
okay maybe omit those a couple of things
and okay just stay here so at the moment
what we have is that we're experimenting
both like we have two ants one ant is
purely statistical methods like word to
back and you try to different statistics
on the owner text and trying to see so
basically building this graph of
knowledge trying to tag every sentence
and then see what are the correlations
and whether what we can see that this
implications between different terms
different mathematical abstractions on
the text and the other the other
approach is purely rule-based meaning
that we're looking for sentences for
example in a text lot like let X be blah
blah blah then we know that this blah
blah blah is actually a mathematical
abstraction mathematical term which we
would like to connect to other
abstractions so but this is something
more based and we try to connect the two
use to get the results and we have like
very say
results so far the whole problem is that
you you want to like machine learning is
statistical and you want to have
something which is more than statistical
you want to have this logic input to it
and it's very hard to do so just like
one of the last comments is that I'm
very open for collaboration this is not
the program for like the next six months
it's more like a research program for
the next ten years basically and I think
like ten years you probably get
something meaningful at this point we're
just trying different stuff that we're
doing the code is ever like we have some
code available publicity on github if
you want to know more then you can write
me okay yeah you can write me at the
email I give you I'm skipping this
because this is more of how how the meta
text would work but this is more from
the mathematical perspective so like I
don't want to get into like type fewer
and stuff like that
yeah in the end I just tell you quickly
that you know that you should have
somehow a library of the facts that you
want to verify that already verified and
then be able to if you get you take the
input you tack it smartly and then you
try to use the logic on it to verify
whether a given fact is compliant with
what you have already in the library but
it's purely on the level of ideas
currently and we are far from it so what
we have is that we trying with this
character rns and then doing something
else but the whole idea is that you
probably can do something like was done
in alphago paper meaning that if you
treat mathematics as a game then you're
trying to win the game by giving a proof
and the way you do it you the tree
itself is too large to actually be able
to go through directly so recall that by
proving a theorem you trying to give a
fact after a fact after a fact that it
that it follows from a given sentence
but the problem is that the tree itself
is growing too too large so you would
like to have some kind of an intuition
and and this is the kind of so the whole
idea is actually similar to what was
done in the first implementation of
alphago where you have both value and
policing networks so but yeah so this is
how we talk to what we are going into so
thank you for your attention if you want
to contact me write me and there's
plenty of things to him to be done
together
thank you
thank you from ik questions regarding
meta tech or fake mathematics do you
have any search for negative examples to
train your your model that verifies the
the correctness you you have to have
both correct and incorrect
now we're mostly doing well I can give
you some incorrect also but which were
training on correct mathematics so far
because it's yeah but I yeah I see what
you mean one more okay so thank you from
ik for talk they've come for Cummings
and pick up Laos
[Applause]
you